[Music]
that was blur the latest single from
singer johnny orlando who joins me now
welcome cool how's it going i'm good i
bet it feels real good to be you right
now though it does it does right
you've been working hard on this
upcoming album but let's talk about blur
that single right there i need to know
the inspo behind it because as i read
this is a story about someone who kind
of came in clutch on the night where you
needed it huh yeah so
the well the song it's it's not a true
story is basically i was in the session
and the producer rants played at that
sample at the beginning in a blur
and you're like blair that's kind of
cool i don't think that's been done
before so we kind of we based the song
around that sample
[Music]
is it fun for you to kind of explore
different characters stories and worlds
within your music like that
for sure i love that that was i never
really realized that you could do that
because you hear people talk about
songwriting and it's like oh yeah this
is very personal yes experience to me
which is cool but i heard like billy
eilish say like she's like she wrote a
song about like uh some gruesome stuff
and uh obviously
not not applicable to her life right
that's really sick i
never realized he could do that tell me
which one is worse
living or dying first so since then a
lot of stuff is either like half true or
just like not true at all i love it um
and it's more fun i find it easier right
to live a fantasy a little bit yeah you
know i feel like taylor swift did that
on folklore finally because you know
she's always written about her own stuff
right but then she says she kind of went
into a different world it's not about
her in that last right right so yeah
there's there's a million creative ways
to go about writing so yeah that's
something that we've been exploring for
sure well blur is totally a breadcrumb
right you're about to service a whole
meal with your debut album how excited
are you to give that to the world
knowing how long and how hard you've
been working on it excited also very
nervous yeah um
i heard somebody say like like when you
finish the album and you just have it
like in a dropbox or or whatever it's
like it's just fully it's all potential
like there's no metric for
for uh like how good your songs are
other than your own ear but then when
you put it out it all becomes uh
like real in a way so and kind of scary
very scary
my debut album as well so yeah um
but yeah are you feeling the love from
the fans i feel like
hopefully they're kind of helping you
curve those nerves a little bit because
they're obsessed for sure yeah it's
definitely helped a lot
[Applause]
here's the album right here it's all the
things that could go wrong uh so you've
been working on it for like what a year
and a half now
um
like two weeks yeah two years yeah like
a year and a half okay yeah we started
conceptualizing it like two years ago
yeah um and even before that i've been
trying to
find this sound for a really long time
i've been doing music since i was eight
so wow
i started writing and i knew what i
wanted but i didn't know how to say it
or or what to
how to do it really but i feel like i've
finally kind of done that it sounds like
you've been preparing for this your
entire life and i know that you have
said about working on your debut album
that it was the most challenging but
rewarding time of your entire career for
sure how so i feel like kind of
everybody says that whenever something's
challenging usually
it's rewarding in the end but especially
when it's the first right oh yeah for
sure like a lot of people can just like
bang out an album or like bang out songs
i can't i can't do that
i i very much nitpick
so to to have this done and have be like
something that i'm happy with i didn't
think that that was going to happen oh
that must be a good feeling yeah i there
was no compromise everywhere which was
one of the
the leading principles no compromises
2021 there's a group chat yeah there's a
group chat there is okay yeah i respect
that well listen you cover a lot of
ground on this record i mean from themes
of anxiety even social media and of
course relationships overthinking and
relationships how's it been like for you
to kind of open up so much in your music
it's really not it's a bit scary a
little bit yeah but mostly just like in
sessions uh like writing sessions having
to actually talk about that stuff is
is uh
a bit apprehensive to do it at first but
yeah uh once you kind of get over that
fear it's a lot easier to
for me at least to like tell the world
things than to tell people i actually
know
[Music]
my biggest thing is like
i i felt very like alone and i was uh
like in my like like prime teenage year
yeah i mean like like a 15 year old dude
is like the most insecure
person on the whole planet i can't
confirm can't confirm that's true
exactly very true so i just wanted
everybody to know because i thought i
was alone yeah
that you know it's a normal thing for
sure and i feel like i don't know that
fear that you have with opening up in
your music and also like literally
giving that to the world is that also
applied when it comes to your social
media because i mean you have such a
huge following right like 25 million
fans on social media you're the number
one universal music group artist on tick
tock with over 8.5 billion views does
the idea of that
number of people kind of watching you
overwhelm you
um
no just because you can't even grasp it
really like imagine 8 million people
i can't
what does that look like i have no i
have no idea i have no idea so
you know i just see the love and i see
the support
[Applause]
[Music]
of course you started gaining popularity
by posting covers of songs right out
from taylor swift rihanna justin bieber
any of those artists on your dream
collab list
all of them
right
to to like do a song with like rihanna
would be really sick or like bieber i
was like the childhood like hero yeah
every like every canadian boy like
whether they admitted it or not was like
people was like oh for sure yeah and
plus he has like some hits right now but
you tell me to go what do you mean
[Music]
oh what do you mean
can i ask you who's at the top of that
dream collab list
i'm a very unreliable source for my for
my own uh collab list uh
switches around a lot i'd say like like
drake i i really like the new album like
stuff that he's doing i know that's
polarizing maybe but i love um yeah so
you're on the same team yeah probably
drake bieber the weeknd i really like
canadians
that part i was gonna say i see the
connection you gotta keep you gotta
stick together right canadians guys
stick together uh well you toured all
over the world and your next stop is
mexico city in a couple of weeks how
excited you to get out there and perform
your music live
fired up i i we just came off like a
little mini run of shows but i've never
done a show in mexico so and it's a
headline as well so very excited
um
i've seen like the the mexican fans on
social media but never in person yes
it'll be fun okay and then are you
setting up a tour for north america like
i don't know are you setting up on some
live shows can i come in here it can't
confirm
or deny but uh after the album usually
people you know
on a little tour so all right i'm
looking forward to it we're gonna have
to find you good thing we know where to
find you actually on social media we
have that that's going for us well thank
you so much for being here thank you uh
lucky for you guys we're gonna have more
of johnny's music video for blur play us
out as we say goodbye we'll see you next
time on et's the download
[Music]
[Music]
you